[Music]
hi I'm Deidre Behar with Entertainment
Tonight now usually when I'm at work
we're talking about Beyonce or Taylor
Swift but today I'm in Corpus Christi
Texas which can really only mean one
thing we're here to pay homage to the
late selena quintanilla at the selena
museum hey ET i'm susie quintanilla and
welcome to the selena museum Selena's
life was taken in 1995 when she was just
23 years old and while I'm no doubt a
fan of all the artists of today I still
find myself so fascinated by Selena's
life and legacy and clearly I'm not
alone I like to sing I want to try to be
the next wheel I think she is an icon
that has been able to really inspire
young women and I think that is great to
have a strong female role models it
wasn't spring - you heard her music
I love inna because she's breathing come
I got to show you this really cool award
the Grammy for our live album when they
said Selena lie the whole world just
jumped up and screamed and then of
course the dress she wore when she won
the Grammy pick tacular Barkley and that
is right here what was your reaction
when you saw her all dolled up in hair
and makeup wearing this gorgeous gown
honestly I think it was the only time
that I really got kind of choked up
because she looked like perfection like
she looked like a true artist and it was
a really cool moment so when you come to
the Selena Museum you expect to see the
costumes and maybe the Grammy what's the
most unexpected item in here well that's
easy what the car oh you want to see the
car yeah everybody kind of freaks out
wouldn't they walk in and they see the
red Porsche this is kind of iconic to
the movie scene where she's got her
hands out the window she just ran off
and got married she had a black Porsche
a brand-new version of the force she had
it for months she didn't like it so she
got rid of the new Porsche to get the
old youth Porsche she'd like to cruise
down by the water with the top off how
many good times did you have in that car
together a lot of good times and she
definitely liked to speed so I think she
got a couple of tickets to let me show
you one
outfit though that she loved to wear and
she designed herself she designed it she
was very cautious though of the fact
that she didn't want it to open up and
anything like that you know something
wardrobe malfunction we wouldn't want
that yeah this is the one concert the
only concert unfortunately that I wasn't
there I had broken my ankle and I didn't
perform at this concert and I really
beat myself up a lot after the fact I
was like I can't believe it I was enough
at last concert at this outfits from the
emot-- buddy the video that she shot in
Joshua Tree California
yeah that's an iconic if you want to
hear a really cool story though this
shirt it's Chris's anything that you saw
Selena just tie there were Chris's
shirts there's one outfit that she wore
for the houston astrodome rodeo and it's
the white beaded one she actually was
putting the pearls on right before her
show she was sitting there with right
red in a needle right and she also did
her boots I saw something over here that
caught my eye
a relic guys this is what cell phones
used to look like this actually was
Salina cell phone that was her personal
cell phone these are more of her
personal items like her jewelry and of
course her dolls this is my office
people I it looks like a little mini
shrine museum also I like to collect a
lot of artwork that the fans create this
right here was done this is in would
here's another one
everything has different meanings to me
the one thing that I do not have here is
her makeup case a lot of people a lot of
Selena's fans want to see her makeup
case and I just can't yet certain things
that I don't mind sharing with her with
her fans and some things that I want to
keep for myself I gave her that makeup
case that's how I ended up back with her
makeup case when we would travel she
would leave her makeup a lot on the
plane so I bought her this really big
makeup case once she passed away Chris
gave it to my mother and my mother gave
it to me she had everything from Chanel
to Lancome to Revlon to Maybelline
[Music]
okay well it's time to go my friend time
together buddy god I'm gonna go ever
thank you thank you for coming see you
next time
[Music]
you
[Music]